it is surprisingly sour right how would
you describe this oh no
look at that look at them so good but
excuse me it smells so good this just
made my day
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okayest
mom and it's a time again I'm going to
make international dishes for one whole
week so I'm only cooking Japanese
recipes for seven whole days and I'm
really excited but also very nervous so
wish me luck I really wanted to make
Japanese food that was attainable and
pretty accessible for me here I didn't
want to make too many substitutions I
also wanted a balance of sweet Savory
and snacks just because it's really fun
to try all sorts of different foods I
want my kids to grow up with diverse
palettes I think that tasting food and
experiencing smells and senses of
different flavors like that is a great
step into cultural appreciation the boys
and I put together our shopping list
there were a lot of specialty
ingredients on there so I called let my
friend Kat who lives in Los Angeles hi
long time no talk how's the family oh my
gosh we're good we're actually doing
something really fun this week you know
how we do our food weeks so I actually
wanted to ask a favor of you sure we are
doing Japanese food for a whole week and
I'm having some trouble sourcing
ingredients yeah that makes sense in the
desert um I've got a Japanese Market
down the street here in Hollywood do you
want me to pop in get some stuff for you
guys and send it your way oh my gosh
that would be amazing because we have a
little list it's like stuff like natto
golden Curry pickled plums um the boys
really want a lot of snacks oh it's all
delicious the snacks especially are my
favorite part okay well I can pay you if
you go take a trip to the store
um how do you want me to send the money
um just send me the money with Zell let
me just pull it up right now awesome
I'll pull up my banking app on my end
too did you get it yes just got it yeah
yay oh my gosh isn't it crazy we have
different banks and it's that easy
honestly the hardest part about these
weeks is sourcing recipes that are
authentic so I got to reach out to mayuk
who works on tasty Japan to give me some
pointers and some advice and recipe
recommendations Japanese foods are easy
to make but also sometimes delicate
Sushi maybe that's the first thing you
can imagine when think about Japanese
food traditionally we have like rice and
fish and miso soup
I'm so excited to try these I just hope
we do it justice back with another
recipe very excited for this one because
I ordered something special from the
Asian market I got these pickled plums
AKA
umuboshi and I'm making onigiri which is
like a rice triangle with a filling I
have my rice and a bowl and I'm gonna
push it around you the purpose of this
week is to try new flavors and scents
and so my kids know what tuna tastes
like my kids know what salmon tastes
like so I wanted to try something
different so I'm really curious to see
how these taste
whoa
really salty
really sour
oh it's like a really good pickle so I
got these plums and tried my best to
form it into these triangles
oh wait what is that is that people's
Plum the subtle sweetness of the rice
the Nori wrapper and then having this
really really tart Center and just
surprisingly sour right
um
it's sour Henry's palette is adjusting
a little too sour
now it wouldn't be a Japanese week
without sampling a lot of Japanese
snacks this was the one thing that the
kids were begging to try Bubba it's
where you lick it and then dip it in the
power
there's such a visual aspect to the
experience of eating so many Japanese
foods and snacks are not left out of
that equation there were sweets there
was Savory Jackson found a new favorite
candy Wyatt was just going to town on
everything and Henry was just begging
for scraps basically okay we are gonna
try one of the suggested snacks I've
been really wanting to try it for a
while it's called natto it's a fermented
soybean I've actually seen a lot of
people taste this too all over the
Internet it smells so good smells nutty
there's I think it's the vinegar and a
mustard the one consensus I've seen in
so many of the taste tests is that
people were not preparing it correctly
the way that I read you have to do it
and I asked a few people how they eat it
and it's definitely use the sauce that
comes with it someone but he also
suggested serve it with some rice with
soy sauce it's one of those foods that I
think is an acquired taste for some
people I think the texture is one of its
most unique aspects I wanted to make
sure we were tasting it respectfully
make a little just for you guys to get a
first taste okay you will never guess
Who Loved this the most take a wild
guess I'll give you a second who wants
to try it first me me
Wyatt wolfed this down
this is so good
what does it taste like
I got stray in my mouth yeah it tastes
kind of like rice and uh some salt salty
it tastes really good how's the texture
I thought it was gonna be hard for a
second oh it's soft yeah that was soft
it's my turn
how would you describe this why it's
having a Whole Bowl it's like nutty
salty
with a lit like with a little bite at
the end almost like a little interesting
aftertaste I tasted
from this sauce that goes on it or maybe
it is from the soybeans it's delicious
we're gonna finish this so the next dish
that I got to make is called Curry udon
little sake now you can make your own
Curry Roux or you can buy it and
honestly when it comes to something like
that I'm just gonna go store-bought and
you want to dissolve this completely
because there's no way I can come close
to making anything as good as the
product that comes from Japan needs a
little more curry
so good we're not like mastering
culinary arts here I definitely
struggled with this recipe I still need
to skim it again but it was really
exciting to try making a broth with
ingredients I've never used to make a
soup base do you know what this is
called chicken cone it's Japanese Curry
udon
mommy kind of like Ramen
a little bit
who made that sound you did
it smells like Curry
yep Curry udon
you like it yeah I'm debating
even leaving the room right now to make
lunch
because it sounds very Rowdy out there I
wanted to make sushi that I was able to
Source correctly in the desert this is
called Tamaki Sushi and it's essentially
a hand roll I really want the kids to
smell and taste the imitation crap now
this felt a little ambitious for me just
because there's a lot of assembly
involved and I wanted to involve the
kids in it second attempt
I'm going to use a little less rice so
that I can Pat it down better I just
really like the taste of this rice and I
think I will add a little
avocado to this ooh
I was nervous that it was just gonna
result in a giant mess and that my kids
would get too silly with it or wouldn't
take it seriously or wouldn't try to
make it correctly but I was so wrong
Tamaki Tamaki you say it Henry Tamaki
Tamaki sushi
you get your Nori you spread your rice
down you lay your hand roll ingredients
and really it's just a ratio of not
overfilling and not overdoing the rice
these are visually stunning one of the
best lunches we've ever had
holy moly so we really don't have much
Asian food at all up here in the desert
but I found something so for dessert for
a little treat after the hand rolls I
picked up some taiyaki I'm so happy to
find it because it takes a special mold
to cook it that I don't have and
probably couldn't get in time
this is sweet potato and I think that's
one of the popular flavors of this
but it smells like a cake it smells oh
it's delicious you want to try it what
does it taste like
[Music]
um
kind of like sweet potatoes yeah
um
[Music]
it tastes like sugar
oh
it's a lighter color oh it tastes so
good in the middle you have to get to
the mail what do you think
this just made my day so after the
success of the Tamaki hand rolls and the
taiyaki I wanted to try something a
little more difficult again and I
decided to make chicken katsu I have my
flour egg Panko bread crumb and I have
salt and peppered chicken thighs so the
two things that are key for this chicken
katsu were thin chicken making sure I
pounded it really thin and breading it
really evenly you want to press this
into the panko so that it sticks really
nicely because
Panko bread crumbs are
so light and fluffy I didn't want to fry
it too long you want to make sure your
oil is hot enough and you want to get a
good crisp all around on that chicken
chicken katsu is one of those beautiful
just like colorful golden amazing dishes
and so I wanted to Plate it alongside
stuff that really complemented it and I
could hear the crunch
[Music]
if I gave you the dip on the side do you
want to try a crispy chicken
okay let's hear it
crunch
you're hearing a good crunch this is the
dish that I would save for a special
occasion it was a lot of work for me I
think just because I need to practice
more I definitely feel like I have a
good grasp of it after that first
attempt but there's always room for
improvement so it's something I will
definitely make again when I have the
time good morning I really want to make
one of those Japanese fruit sandwiches
it seemed a little too simple so I'm
gonna try to make my own Japanese milk
bread from scratch and use that bread to
make the fruit sandwiches so I got my
starter ready I got my ingredients
prepped and I decided I wanted to double
this recipe because
I wanted to make it worth my while I
wanted two loaves out of this
I'm already off to a terrible start so
the reason I doubled it is because the
amount of starter in the recipe is for
two loaves and so I was gonna double the
rest but I already doubled the starter
so now I have enough for
four loaves
so we've got the Aesthetics and the
beauty of the fruit and that whole
assembly and then we've got the milk
bread which could go so very wrong oh my
gosh how am I gonna do this
it says form it into a ball
how am I supposed to do that when it's
so sticky okay I have it in a bowl I'm
going to cover this
and it needs to rest in a warm spot for
40 to 60 minutes it's one of the wildest
recipes I've ever made because it's just
like puffing up like crazy we're rolling
around
beautiful delicate
delicate
beautiful dough brush out the oven
whoa
oh my goodness oh my goodness it's like
eating a cloud it is a milk-based white
bread that is super fluffy
what do you think that's good
what do you think
don't eat that one do you like it
do you want it okay so I got mango kiwi
and strawberry mostly because that's
what was ripe at my grocery store and
that's what I could get oh no
this is a lot harder than it looks I
swear it looks cuter in person well it's
just just look at this slice
is it yummy
you ate the Kiwi do you want to take a
bite of the sandwich
okay try it why so
cute
I kind of like to eat the fruit I would
absolutely make the milk bread again
that is something that just can't be
bought it is so good if you
live near
a Japanese Bakery run if you can find
some milk bread
run I'm gonna be making Kansai style
okonomiyaki because this is mayuk's
Hometown and he sent me the recipe it is
a cabbage pancake with meat and amazing
toppings like two different sauces and
all of this wild stuff I got Bonito
flakes which is dried tuna and from what
I've seen of these they can move around
sometimes
um and I think it's gonna be so cool and
knowing my boys I think they're gonna
flip out over having these on top first
attempt down let's see I think I have my
feet too high
so what I wanted to do was make a test
pancake just to try it myself and
improve for whatever the kids were going
to try so I assembled it all it has a
couple different sauces okay I got the
Bonito open I'm really excited to see
it smells really good it smells smoky
well excuse me
I was a little nervous to see how my
kids would react to the Bonito flake
okay do you want to know what this is
called what
Bonito flakes
and it's really really thinly sliced so
so so thin that when there's any heat
that means it moves look at that look at
them
my kids are not huge cabbage people and
so I was excited for them to try this
because I thought it could be
the dish that makes them like cabbage
honestly
yeah
it looks like pancakes
[Music]
any description I use is not going to do
this Justice because it is so delicious
as I was cooking Japanese food this week
there was another huge project in the
works and that's why Matt wasn't with us
for the majority of this week so at the
end of this week the kids and I needed
to travel we are in La we're visiting my
mom and you know what La has a lot of
Japanese restaurants I had been cooking
a lot this week but there was one more
dish we really wanted to try and that
was yakisoba it was a great way to
finish out the week before another crazy
project full of so much work Stars it
smells so good are you ready yeah okay
are you eating with your chopsticks
how's the Yaki soba try it okay
you want some yakisoba you have it right
there on your plate you were using your
chopsticks that's really good he did it
have you had those noodles before
how they taste
so after this week of Japanese food and
after doing this several times with so
many International dishes I just feel
like it keeps getting better and better
I feel like we're getting a better grasp
on how to Source our recipes how to
Source our ingredients and so it's
something I just want to keep doing
forever honestly seeing the Joy on my
kids faces as they're enjoying another
culture's Cuisine is priceless so that's
all for now I'm Hannah and what did you
think of Japanese week were there any
recipes I missed let me know on
Instagram and if you try any of these
please message me a picture or if you
have any other suggestions of other
countries Cuisine that I should be
cooking yes yep did you like the
Japanese food
[Music]
thank you